les ministres russe et turc des affaires
étrangères se sont rencontrés afin de
parler des sujets qui fâchent à savoir
les grands dossiers de géopolitique sur
lesquels les deux pays ne sont pas
d'accord mais comme souvent ils ont
néanmoins réussi à avancer concernant
par exemple la création d'un centre de
contrôle russe aux turcs dans le
haut-karabakh ils ont aussi évoqué la
libye où le ministre turc des affaires
étrangères a tenu à rappeler la position
de son pays personne n'a le droit de
dire que la turquie est obligé de
quitter la libye
les gouvernements peuvent changer mais
nous avons des liens historiques avec la
libye il approche des pays occidentaux
vis-à-vis de la libye est différente de
la nôtre nous n'y sommes pas allés pour
défendre des intérêts est imaginaire
nous sommes présents là bas en vue d'une
coopération mutuellement bénéfique et la
séquence libyenne va continuer pour
sergueï lavrov avec la venue demain à
moscou de son homologue libyen la
situation en libye est très compliqué
dans le sud il y a eu des incidents
violents les accords de cessez le feu il
n'y a pas si longtemps
ayew mais depuis la situation s'est
globalement stabilisé et les accords
signés cet été ont été dans l'ensemble
respectées cela doit être encouragé tout
doit être fait pour consolider ces
accords y compris à l'aide du soutien du
comité militaire mixte 5 5
créé par les différentes parties
prenantes le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a tenu lui aussi à faire le
point sur la situation en libye tout en
n'oubliant pas de rappeler ce qu'il
estime être les causes du conflit à
savoir l'intervention de l'otan en 2011